Victoria's Secret has a really evil  secret they don't want you to know about  every year skinny tan beautiful girls as  young as 17 that are willing to do  anything for their career are recruited  from all over the world to walk the  runway in tantalizing lingerie nothing  could go wrong here right well as it  turns out the owner of Victoria's Secret  Lex Wexner was best friends with  everyone's favorite Private Island owner  and free Jeff's theme yes the owner of  the biggest lingerie brand that employs  underage girls was not just business  partners but close friends with the man  that didn't kill himself they were so  close that Wexler called him a most  loyal friend with excellent judgment and  unusually high standards click the link  in the pinned comments and watch the  full documentary to learn more